c'est délicieux même si elle garde le
moral le coeur de mireille est très
abîmé c'est la pompe du cac qui fait
défaut qu'il faut charger novembre
dernier elle apprend que sa valve
aortique doit être changé et qu'une de
ses artères cardiaque et bouche et elle
fait quatre allers-retours mont-laurier
montréal pour passer des examens à
l'hôpital sacré-coeur 2000 km de routes
en quelques semaines pour finalement
apprendre qu'elle doit être opéré le
dernier qui move à la bouche la qui
m'aura a dream caméra ici pour aller
voir le car
il y avait ici avait gardé tous comme
halak a fonctionné société m'a ordonné
l'examen a fini 16e madame ici ça va
être bientôt votre opération
c'était votre dessin
avec le sixième vague le réseau de la
santé peine à rattraper le retard
accumulé en chirurgie l'augmentation du
nombre d'employés infectés par la coved
a ralenti les chirurgies entre le 19
mars et le 6 avril le taux d'activité
des salles d'opération du québec a donc
baissé de 86 à 81%
le délestage s'est accélérée dans la
majorité des établissements comme des
milliers d'autres
miré gaudreault doit prendre son mal en
patience c'est juste que les films a
répondu on est servi ma mère me dit on
en paie une pile de dossiers en attente
the dead et 10,6 sur la paix la vo
baissé
mais moi quand est ce que je vaux pas
c'est difficile à dire surtout que le
nombre de patients en attente de
chirurgie est passé de 156 1000 à 159
milles depuis janvier mireille pense
qu'elle passe après les plus jeunes
parce qu'elle a maintenant 81 ans est
latente la rend anxieux zh est plutôt
pessimistes pensent pas de la rondelle à
l'opération comme ça vaut l'homme
ils vont avoir ma peau
ben il plaît ici david gêne-t-il et
radio canada montréal